[Music]
hello minimizers welcome to the
minimalist podcast where we discuss what
it means to live a meaningful life with
less my name is joshua fields milburn
and i'm ryan nicodemus and together we
are the minimalists ryan how much stuff
is enough stuff
how much stuff is too much stuff
that's what we're talking about today on
the public podcast then this thursday on
the minimalist private podcast ryan and
i are going to discuss
calendar clutter the meetings schedules
lunches conferences dinners play dates
extracurricular activities family
outings and various other obligations
that are stressing out everybody you can
check that out at patreon.com
the minimalists also ryan i want to talk
to you about my oldest possession
which just
well i'm not even going to go into it
right now okay i'll talk to you about
that on the private podcast intriguing
patreon.com the minimalist your support
keeps our podcast and youtube channel
100 advertisement free and i want you to
say it with me folks because
advertisements suck i imagine they're
people like in their car right now just
yelling
advertisements suck
it's one of my favorite things when we
do a live event yeah we have a thousand
people say advertisements suck pretty
cool just a cacophony and there's like
three people who work in advertising
were there they like have their arms
crossed and they're kind of upset at us
at the beginning of the event
you know it's funny
like a lot of people half the crowd will
add an s
to the suck
at the end and i always want to be like
it's not plural it's singular
but then i'm like that's not that big of
a deal but i notice that every single
time like half the crowd says
advertisement sucks
interesting so like if it's one ad it's
like it's an ad for some male hair
regrowing product you could say that
advertisement sucks yes
but we don't have any advertisements
folks so thank you for your support
patreon.com
the minimalist let's go ahead and dive
into our first question of the day it's
from myra on patreon
my mom is a hoarder and we're working
through her house together how can we
avoid burnout or complacency while going
through generations of stuff
so burnout is where you already are
right now yeah you're burnt out by the
stuff by the hoarding by the excess now
your mom
is asking you i assume
to work through this stuff with her you
didn't show up at a hoarder's house and
say hey you know what today mom we're
getting rid of your stuff
that's theft
and also that's a way to ruin our
relationship and it's also a way to
stress someone else out
to tell them they need to get rid of
stuff to get rid of their stuff for them
or just to simply tell someone oh look
you have too much stuff
that's not loving no not at all
man well i think it's cool that her mom
is has asked her to help her i mean that
is uh
that's that's a pretty big deal i i
can't tell you how many hoarders we come
across and they're like how do i get my
partner how do i get my mother how do i
get my brother like how do i get them to
start decluttering and the thing is is
you can't like there is no there is no
uh magic thing that you can say to
someone and all of a sudden they're
gonna like get get rid of all their
stuff they are not gonna get rid of
their stuff until they want to and
that's exactly where mars mom's at
that's pretty pretty cool uh i like i
like what you said about the burnout
it's interesting because once we start
talking about burnout you're right it's
already too late right so right now uh
mara um you're burnt out that's okay i
think for me when i feel burnt out i
have to have some type of plan some type
of light at the end of the tunnel so you
know maybe just kind of planning day by
day little chunking here and there how
do you eat an elephant you eat an
elephant one bite at a time yes
i was gonna say with a fork yeah right
so bring a fork meyer now yes here's
here's what i'll say is
letting go decluttering whatever you
want to call it is supposed to bring
freedom not burnout
you're already at the place of burnout
and so by letting go of the stuff but
not just the stuff because you could let
go of the stuff
physically but not let go of it
psychologically emotionally so what
we're really talking about here is a
complete letting go how do you let go
you stop clinging
letting go is simply
refusing to continue to hold on refusing
to continue to need those things that
you thought you need it's the most
freeing thing in the world when you
realize you don't need the things you
thought you needed
all of a sudden there's a freedom when
you don't need a particular outcome when
you don't need those material
possessions anymore because if you still
need them and you get rid of the thing
but you need them emotional you need
them psychologically you're going to get
dragged by that stuff after you donate
it or sell it or get rid of it so i'm
thinking about one thing though i don't
want to be a complete legalist about
this it's not about getting down to a
particular number of items sure you and
i were just out in ohio we had a tour
stop in columbus the love people use
things tour you can find all of the
recordings that we have there over on
our website the minimalists.com
previous for all of our previous tour
stops but myra i was thinking about this
someone asked about the how many things
that we own it reminded me of this
story early on when we first created the
minimalists.com
one of the first things that i wrote was
the 288 items that i own
and
i was 29 years old at the time and it
was a parody of other people's counting
i haven't seen any blog posts or stories
like this in a while but it it was you
know a very in vogue
when we became the minimalist it just so
happened we were at a time where like
everyone had these
um these these blog posts about how many
things they owned and i think who won
who won that battle josh did anyone
actually win that though yeah i mean i
think it was remember the the guy who
did the joseph kony thing
remember uh
and because he was naked in the street
masturbating at a traffic light so he
had zero yeah did he write about it
though
he didn't have a pen
[Laughter]
that's good man um i
the one that stands out the most to me i
think it was nina yao which she's
amazing i love nina um she uh
what she what did she have like my 15 15
things my 15 things yes yeah and what we
realized early on that's why i created
this thing it was 288 items that i own
but even then i noticed these people who
were counting like our friend colin he
owned 52 things but it was like a pair
of socks was one thing and i'm like well
wait a minute kyle and that's two things
what if i count the individual threads
in there then maybe it's way more than
two things and the point was i want to
do this in a joking yet loving
compassionate way to show people like i
counted my bookshelf as one thing
i counted my sock drawers one thing yeah
yeah and the point wasn't that to get
down to 288 items or 15 items or 52
items i didn't want to be a legalist i
wanted to have fun with this because
there was freedom in that fun it wasn't
about
competing because that's a competition i
would have lost and i was already tired
of competing we had competed so much in
the corporate world and that competing
was a sort of psychological trap it was
a prison
i wanted to break out of the prison of
competing and so when you're letting go
of the horde with your mom it's not
about getting down to a specific number
or having a perfect house just like the
stuff didn't make you more complete
letting go of the stuff isn't going to
make you complete you are already
complete you're just getting rid of the
things that are in the way yeah and if
you're just focused on the number of
things
then
you're missing the larger point of what
minimalism is consumption is not the
problem it's the compulsive consumerism
like that is the problem and if we're
counting our things well in a way in a
weird way it's it just goes right back
to the consumption that's right yeah
yeah it's it's a reverse consumption
away reverse consumerism let's move on
to our callers ryan if you have a
question or comment for our podcast give
us a call
406-219-7839 or send a voice memo to
podcast at theminimalists.com
it looks like uh monique has a question
from anaheim california i am drawing a
fine line between the hoarding and here
onto clothes toys
you know anything that you could
basically sell at a guard style
and
the hardest part for me is
making time for the yard sale because i
won't be able to host it at my place of
residence
i have to go to my in-laws you know
where they live in a neighborhood
um you know they're not in a gated
community
um where i live
so
i'm just wondering um
where would you draw that line as to
what to say for yard sale and you know
what to donate
yeah uh where's that line between what
do you sell versus what do you donate if
you can sell it and recoup a little bit
of the cost i mean
absolutely sell it i think uh like for
you now we had that 20 mark if we could
sell it for 20 or more we put it up for
sale um and then if it didn't sell
within a certain amount of time uh then
we would let it go yeah so if what is
the line for you in fact we're going
through this right now with alabama
she's selling some of the excess stuff
that we have in our studio as we built
out the studio we had some temporary
things a desk and a chair and some
camera equipment some wires cables
lighting etc some things that we need to
sell some things that we need to donate
so here's our how to let go process and
then you can adjust it to create
boundaries for you first off if you want
to let go of something try to sell it if
it costs more than x dollars now you get
to determine what that x is in fact
alabama for us right now it's around a
hundred dollars in my life it's a
hundred bucks when i was in debt as ryan
mentioned twenty dollars because
anything that i could sell to get money
to pay off debt now if it was something
that was fifty cents or two dollars or
something it may not be worth investing
the time money attention energy and
trying to sell that thing to get that
money it's best to just get it out of
the way but if you can sell it if it's
over that threshold yours might be 20
bucks it might be 100 bucks i have some
friends where it's 200 whatever it is if
you can sell it great if it doesn't sell
in the first week alabama lower the
price
and then if it doesn't sell in 30 days
you want to donate it if you can't
donate donate it you try to recycle it
if you can't recycle it eventually it
will make its way to the trash but if
you go through that entire cycle what
you're realizing is i'm gonna sell a
bunch of things what are you gonna do
with that money if you're in debt you're
gonna use that money to pay off the
credit cards pay off the mortgage pay
off the lenders whatever it might be or
maybe you can take that money
that you had there wasted away on these
useless things that were just collecting
dust in the attic or a storage closet or
whatever in fact in a few weeks around
we're going to do a whole episode about
storage we're calling it clutter coffins
and the whole obsession that we have
here's a preview for you ryan did you
know that america
has 90 percent of the storage facilities
in the world what 90
did you know that there are over 52 000
storage facilities across the united
states so that's 90 of them right there
52 000. yeah it's more than six times
the number of starbucks
[Laughter]
just uh map out the top of my head did
you know that all americans if they
stood under the roof
of a storage of the storage facilities
they would all fit in the storage
facilities in america
all americans could fit into the storage
facilities that's how many we have and
wow that's an indicator of how much
stuff we have
so monique
if you have a lot of stuff and you're
burdened by it and you want to sell it
you need to develop a threshold if
you're in debt it's probably somewhere
around 20 bucks
sell it in seven days if it doesn't sell
lower the price if it goes below 20
bucks donate it if you can't donate it
you can recycle it if you can't recycle
it eventually the last resort absolute
last resort we can trash it it's already
trash anyway it's just is the trash heap
in your home or is the trash heap well
is it in a landfill in fact next week
ryan we're talking with claire potter
about
environmentalism and sustainable living
and so we'll have a deeper conversation
about recycling and other things like
that monique i'd love to give you a copy
of our book essential there's 12 areas
of intentional living and one of those
areas has to do with our priorities and
so unfortunately we prioritize our stuff
in our lives
much more than the things that are truly
important to us in fact we've
prioritized a lot of things if you have
two dozen priorities
it's literally nonsensical the word
priority did not have a
plural until the 20th century
and so if you say i have
20 priorities
priority simply means the first thing
you can't have 20 the first things
you can have a first thing and right now
your priority is getting rid of the
excess in your home and if you follow
that simple recipe and then adjust the
dollar amounts accordingly in alabama if
you do that here with the microphones
we're selling or the extra lights or any
other that we had a few bistro tables
that we were using for a while some old
stools
if we follow that then within 30 days
we'll have all of that out of our lives
and it's not that we're against having
things or having even a storage facility
with some things right
the storage isn't the problem it's our
clinging to all that stuff we have too
much stuff because
we have a desire for too much we have a
desire for more thinking that well ryan
mentioned consumerism being the problem
earlier what is consumerism buying
something is going to make me more
complete or more happy but we know the
opposite is true often the objects of
our desire become the objects of our
discontent yeah and so if you want to
let go of the discontent it has much
more to do with letting go of the excess
stuff yeah you said that uh this is a
very simple recipe we have presented to
monique here and it is but simple is not
easy simple takes a lot of work and i
can hear it in monique's voice and her
voicemail she's a little overwhelmed
that's okay use that as leverage to uh
get at this thing but but yeah i think
unfortunately we too often confuse
simple with easy and that is that is not
the case yeah
shout out to our patreon supporters if
you want to join us during the live
streams we do a live stream most weeks
over at patreon.com the minimalist we
live stream this version of the podcast
as well as the maximal version of the
podcast we also answer some questions
that don't make it on to the podcast
ryan what time is it you know what time
it is josh it's time for the lightning
round where we answer your text messages
you can text your questions your
comments your smart remarks your emojis
to 937-202-4654
oh by the way ryan uh monique we're
giving her a copy of our book essential
the 12 different areas of intentional
living one of those priorities we also
have a chapter about stuff in there a
chapter about technology and there are
like 12 different areas of intentional
living it's an essay collection with
150 different essays if you like our
podcast we think you'll enjoy the
audiobook version of that now during the
lightning round ryan this is where we do
our best to answer questions with a
short shareable less than 140 character
response we put the text to these
minimal maxims in the show notes so you
can copy and share our pithy answers on
social media if you like and now you can
find all of our minimal maxims in one
place
minimal
maxims.com big thanks to our good friend
jessica lynne williams over there for um
for helping out with that social jess
allison has a question for us
how do we accept household family
members who consume so much stuff it
makes us uncomfortable
so to accept someone maybe another word
here is i'm having trouble liking them
yeah right
and so because accepting them or loving
them
doesn't require
the that we
are on the same page with them that we
have the same beliefs that we have the
same stuff or the same needs or the same
desires you can love someone and be in a
completely different space than them
yeah
but maybe the question here for allison
is
how do we
how do i like them how do i
tolerate or appreciate them in a way
here's my pithy answer for you maybe we
can unpack this ryan the stuff doesn't
make us miserable clinging to stuff does
i'm a minimalist
but i can go to a we actually have a
picture of me and you ryan we were with
jordan no more podcast sean we were over
in playa vista and they were there was
this horde of stuff we took a picture in
front of it they used it on netflix for
our last documentary uh less is now and
there's a picture of me and you in front
of all of this stuff
there's heaps and heaps of useless
things useless to us useful to someone
else yeah
and
in that picture you and i are smiling
well why is that
because we're not clinging to any of
that stuff we that stuff can't make me
miserable
unless i allow it to make me miserable
now that's not to say that if you are
living with someone
who is a hoarder
that they can inflict their preferences
on you and create a space that is a
little more chaotic than your preference
but right now what you're talking about
is accepting them wherever they are in
life because maybe it took you a while
to become a minimalist maybe it took me
and ryan 30 years to become minimalists
and so when we started letting go
it wasn't just about letting go of the
stuff it was about not clinging to it
anymore realizing that oh
i am complete right here right now
anyone else's stuff
it's not really my concern it's not my
problem um man my pithy answer is this
judgment is but a mirror reflecting the
insecurities of the person who's doing
the judging so right here allison is
projecting a little judgment that she's
feeling and that's okay i do the same
exact thing i will look at someone i i
got a couple examples in my head but i
don't think i want to talk public about
them maybe i'll bring them up in the
maximum
maximal podcast but i can think of a
specific time recently i was judging
this person for a certain thing
and i caught it and i'm like what am i
doing like why
am i feeling this this judgment and
especially like why am i projecting this
judgment
and what i was able to do is i was able
to actually hold a mirror up to myself
and say what does this judgment actually
have to say about me as a person yeah
and i was able to get a little bit
deeper and uh instead of you know
judging i actually um was able to i
don't know like root for that person i
was able to like find compassion that's
what it is i was able to find compassion
towards that person yes so really alison
the question is how can you find
compassion towards uh your friend's
family whoever it is that is consuming
too much and she does say consuming too
much so i don't know exactly what
they're consuming maybe they're eating
too many hot dogs i don't know man maybe
they're like i can't believe they're
eating that many hot dogs whatever it is
it's a judgment that really is saying
something about you as a person allison
and if you can get to the deeper cause
of why you're feeling this judgment then
you might be able to find some
compassion and compassion leads to love
well it's a really great point ryan
because
when you say they're consuming too much
what you're really saying because of
that mirror they're consuming too much
for you if i were in his or her shoes
that would be too much for me now
granted you're in a shared living space
and there may come a time in that shared
living space where you have to have an
exit plan where it doesn't make sense if
their things or their activities their
behaviors are getting in the way of you
living a meaningful life or even a
peaceful life consistently i mean that's
the nature of relationships any
relationship
is going to cause some bit of chaos in
your life even the most peaceful if
you're a monk at a monastery another
monk is going to do something that's
going to drive you crazy at some point
so that's not what we're talking about
but if someone is constantly encroaching
on your boundaries you've created your
own space maybe it's your own room you
have your own sort of sanctuary and
wherever you go you can still be a
minimalist even amid the chaos you can
be calm in the middle of times square
and you can be a middle minimalist in
the middle of a horde
ryan we got a bunch more to talk about
but first real quick for right here
right now here is one thing or four
things going on in the life of the
minimalists unfortunately we had to
reschedule a few of our tour stops the
love people use things tor is supposed
to be over right now
but we had to move while we had a bunch
of weather in ohio ice storm oh my
goodness we got trapped yeah
i got sick yes oh my goodness mariah got
sick it was funny there was like
this two-week period um like it started
with our flight getting delayed
and we're like okay no worries and then
i got canceled we're like okay maybe we
could still somehow finagle it and still
make it to chicago and then basically
flights got canceled for two days mariah
comes down uh with covid i came down
with it um we were trapped in ohio for
like a week it was just funny because
like just one thing after the other yeah
and instead of
i don't know instead of like keeping me
down or like making me think like whoa
is me i was just kind of like you know
what like this is what life does
sometimes it just like it just starts
swinging at you and you to roll with the
punches man yeah so uh this is wrong
with the punches we're rescheduling
we're gonna have some awesome events uh
in these four cities looking forward to
it have we decided to add anything to
canada we're we're trying to so we have
four cities right now we have four more
tour stops and a lot of people use
things towards chicago it's minneapolis
and that's the that's it for the united
states
and then we have toronto and vancouver
there's a small chance we'll add
montreal and calgary stay tuned for that
the minimalists.com tour for all of
those dates i will tell you this because
we had to move everyone's tickets
transferred over so some of those are
really close to selling out so get your
tickets now while you can if you want to
attend one of those events we're not
adding additional events in any of those
cities so whatever is left is what is
left at this point if we do add montreal
and calgary maybe
in the future then stay tuned you can
also put your email address on our
website if you want to be notified of
any future tour stops of course we won't
send you spam or advertisements or junk
but you already know that alabama you
got anything else for us right now here
are some voicemail comments and insights
from our listeners
g'day guys this is tristan from owling
in germany
i wanted to share an efficient way to
follow the news without having to
compulsively check all the time or
relying on some social media algorithm
so what i do is i use rss feeds for all
the content i'm interested in
most websites that have some sort of
news feed allow you to copy an rss link
into an rss reader app
when you subscribe to an rss feed all
new articles from the website will show
up in your rss reader
when you open an article in the reader
it gets marked as read you can filter
out read articles so once you've read
something it will no longer take up any
space
some websites have a dedicated button
from which you can copy the rss link
into a reader
however with a lot of websites that
don't explicitly advertise their rss
feed you can just copy the url from your
address bar
this way you can for example subscribe
to youtube channels without even having
a google account
it also works with podcasts as podcast
links typically rely on the rss standard
so you can really have all your content
in one place
the reader that i use is called feedbin
it's an online reader which syncs to all
my devices
the cool thing about feedbin is you can
filter incoming articles by keywords and
automatically perform actions on them
for example i've subscribed to the
economist's asia feed but i'm really
just interested in use concerning
australia not so much the rest of the
region
so i have feedback mark any articles in
the asia feed as you read that don't
contain the word australia
these automations can actually be much
more complex allowing you to save a heap
of time
feed bin is five us dollars a month or
50 us dollars a year
there is a similar alternative called
inner reader which also has a free
version
if you're new to the whole thing i would
recommend you try out the free version
or one of many other free readers and
see whether you actually need any
automation tools or other extra features
you can then still switch as it's very
easy to export all your feeds in a
single file and import them to another
reader much like transferring bookmarks
when switching
browsers hi my name's karen i'm calling
from hertfordshire in the uk
i'm calling with some tips today for
anyone who's been through bereavement
recently it's a tough thing to go
through and you still have to deal with
all the objects that are left behind and
that's been quite a difficult process
for me number one tip is remembering
that the love is not in the object the
love you have for that person is not in
the objects that's a thing that i've
heard before in the podcast but it's
been my little motto for dealing with
this my my father passed away in january
and i've had a lot of objects and things
to go through of here so i've just been
saying that over and over for myself and
it's been very very helpful my love for
him is in the things i did for him when
he was alive the times i told him i
loved him and in my memories that i
carry with me for the rest of my life
number two and this wouldn't be for
everyone is that i've chosen to make a
memory bear out of some of his old
clothing you can just find online if you
google memory there there's lots of
different companies i've gone with one
in the uk called lily's love that i
found on facebook but not just for
bereaved people's clothing also they can
make wedding dresses bears out of
wedding dresses there's out of old baby
clothing so if your children have grown
up it's another good thing that you
could think about doing with the clothes
the third thing is just remembering that
the greatest object my parents could
bequeath me is me my flesh my blood they
chose to raise me and that's an amazing
gift the gift of life and it's really
important that i hang on to that i was
surprised baby so they didn't have to
have me but they carried on and i know
parents aren't always brilliant they
don't always make the best choices but
they chose to try they chose to try and
raise me well and i know that i only
honour that gift if i spend the time now
looking after myself as i live my life
rather than spreading over some old
crockery or cds so i hope those tips
help someone i'm sending out my love to
anyone who's going through the same
experience at the moment
all right y'all before we get to our
added value segment this week let's read
a quick testimonial from one of our
lovely patreon supporters this one is
from emil e
and he or she says whoa this private
podcast episode the signifiers of
suffering might be the most important
thing i've ever listened to
i'm supposed to go to therapy today and
i don't even know if i need it now
wow that's incredible we're not telling
you to skip your therapy but hey maybe
if you just if you're one of our patreon
supporters you'll save money on therapy
yeah it's definitely cheaper than
therapy you know what ryan uh for our
added value this week we were listening
to this
while we were out on tour and i remember
i turned it on it's this band called
yard act and the album is called the
overlord
and the song is called rich
and we were playing it and you looked
you stopped me in the car and you're
like where did you start listening to
good music
because it seemed a little bit outside
of the norm of what i might listen to
yeah it's like alternative sort of post
punk i guess yeah i don't know what you
would label it but what really stood out
to me in this song in particular are the
opening lyrics so here are the opening
lyrics almost by accident i have become
rich
through continued reward for skilled
labor in the private sector and a
genuine lack of interest in expensive
things it appears i have become rich and
since i have become rich i've been
constantly living in fear
of losing everything
that's the thing about our things we get
the thing it doesn't make us happy but
now we're terrified to let it go yeah
and so enjoy this this song it's called
rich by yard act by the way ryan we have
a bunch more surprise questions this
week like how do you determine what
routine appointments like medical
checkups and car tune-ups are most
important and which ones can wait how do
you make time in your calendar for
spontaneity do you have any tips and
tricks for laying out your schedule and
calendar to optimize your life plus a
million more questions about calendar
clutter for me and for ryan and if you
want to hear all that check out the
minimalist private podcast this week
visit
patreon.com
the minimalists to subscribe and get
your personal link so that our weekly
private podcast plays in your favorite
podcast app you'll also gain immediate
access to hundreds of hours of private
archives recordings of live events
exclusive home tours and our private
community of thousands of open-minded
minimizers like you you can follow the
minimalists on tick tock instagram
facebook and twitter at the minimalist
if you want our podcast show notes in
your inbox sign up for our email list
over at
theminimalists.com on behalf of ryan
nicodemus podcast sean alabama jordan no
more social jess danny unknown emma the
immigrant and the rest of our team i'm
joshua fields milburn reminding you to
love people and use things
because the opposite never works thanks
for listening y'all we'll see you next
time
every little thing
you think that you need
every little thing
you think that you need
every little thing
that's just feeding your greed oh i bet
that you'll be fine
without it